Bobbi Kristina Browns former boyfriend  Nick Gordon arrested for domestic  violence et can confirm 28-year old Nick  was arrested in Sanford Florida on  Saturday afternoon after an altercation  with his current girlfriend according to  a spokesperson for the Johnny Polk  Correctional Facility Nick is facing two  charges of kidnap false imprisonment and  battery is currently being held at no  bail the arrest comes just one month shy  of the two-year anniversary since Bobbi  Kristina's death Whitney Houston's  daughter died on July 26th 2015 nearly  six months after she was found facedown  in a bathtub in a home she and Gordon  shared in September 2016 Gordon was  found liable for Brown's death and in  November he was ordered to pay thirty  six million dollars in her wrongful  death suit